hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and I'm Kody Belcher and this is Tamara
Jessa and Cody also just saw two as well
scholastically tonight Cody and I went
saw eighth grade or as I like to call it
a grade Hey look so weird when it's
written it all bleeds together it's all
bad I had the worst time I had no
friends i was deeply uncool and i was
trying so hard and that this was so
relatable because she is trying so hard
and i can't we were talking about this
in the car i can't imagine having social
media in middle school right
i have it now as an adult and i'm mess
with it like it it truly ruins multiple
moments of every day of my life oh yeah
and so to have that in middle school
with instagram are you kidding me no way
no that would've been terrible that's
fine thank you
they can't get you any more they do it's
a very formative time period and a very
transformative time period it's an
interest communits middle school it's an
interstitial time period yeah and i
think that's why it gets spotlit more
than high school because like i think
for some people high schools sometimes
worse yeah but it's more defined there's
there's like a there's there's stuff
happening like my high school was worse
because I didn't kill arms anybody in my
high school and I was also trying to
figure out my sexuality and stuff and so
that's all very specific in middle
school you lack the skills and tools
available to understand why things
aren't going well you're still a child
but you're dealing with adult issues on
the hero's journey it's very just
watching obi-wan get killed and you're
like I don't know what the horse is yet
really you know you haven't gone to Yoda
you don't know anything that's going on
yet you're still in this kind of weird
making out with your sister vibe and
you're not quite sure where to go from
there so I don't want to talk about this
too much because we're gonna address
this in next week's episode we just
watched to all the boys I've loved
before on that
like they portray all of these
characters as like he's just cool as ice
like that's a movie I've seen cool is
really cool
yeah yes sir first like this was like
you're clearly a middle schooler who's
dealing with mental health issues and I
believed every second of it and it was
hard to watch cuz he was so awkward the
climax of the film where I heard her dad
in my mind the climax her and her dad
have this like heart-to-heart and he
tells the emotional climax yes yeah that
could have been so much bigger there
could have been so many more like
emotional wells that could have drawn
from and like made it like a more
tear-jerking moment but because it was
so like beautifully mundane because
they're just personal to those two
characters it was more sad and more
emotional more impactful to me Oh even
though he was a YouTube comedian it's
still a youtuber it's just kind of
presenting the light which is a very
YouTube thing it's you know it's a very
cinema veritas thing yeah I was just
kind of like yeah this is weird I'm just
gonna I'm not I'm not really making any
qualitative judgments necessarily she is
cuz there you know I feel like a lot of
the way that she's portrayed I feel like
a lot of the way other people are
portrayed it's not just how they are
it's also how she views things like she
views herself in certain ways and she
these other people in certain ways and
anything that's anything that's made
it's a judgment call on other people is
is because she's making a judgment call
on them the movie itself is not
necessarily trying to make a statement
because I don't think there really is a
statement to be made I think I think
it's just kind of like yeah pretty
similar to boyhood I thought that about
Lady Bird too like I was Lady Bird yes
yes much just like this is oh god lady
bird living through their lives a part
of it is also that her videos are not
getting views you know like it's not
like she's she's got like a small cadre
of people who are talking
what is it like when you abused it
wasn't like 114 views yeah 67 views it
was like one view zero views yeah I
loved that so much because she was
making these for herself right she was
making these because she felt so
insecure and that is so I oh man it was
so relatable I think I think the YouTube
videos were also kind of like a homing
beacon kind of a deal like I think she
was throwing them out like like like
like a modern day of messages and
bottles yeah she's throwing around she's
hoping someone will find but I do agree
with you that I think it's also for her
because a lot of them are lessons about
her lying about herself basically and in
that I think something I really admired
about the film is that it doesn't go too
far like it feels real there's no like
crazy moments where cuz like I cringed a
lot during it because I identified with
it but like there weren't moments where
I was just like unbearably like oh no I
can't believe she's doing that that's
crazy she wasn't doing anything that was
crazy she was just doing things that
matched her in one moment you looked at
me and you saw me doing this she's seen
she said a birthday party she doesn't
want to be at and no one's being
welcoming to her there and then
everyone's doing karaoke and and she
walks up and at the same time a video of
her talking about courage is playing and
she takes the mic and she started
singing and I thought at some point
maybe the music was gonna cut off and it
was gonna reveal it she was like doing
something embarrassing but it was
actually like a beautiful moment of her
like having courage and despite the
other things in the film this was like a
beautiful triumphant moment but while it
was happening I was so worried it was
gonna be like this thing because I
didn't want to be overdramatic and and
it wasn't it was perfect also her dad
what did he's amazing that I was so good
I will say I love her dad and I relate a
lot to her dad and I also think that
like as an adult when you watch this
movie you relate a lot to the father my
only problem with the dad is I felt like
he was like too perfect sometimes like
yeah like he just never did anything he
never did anything wrong like the things
he did wrong were still that he was a
really good
and they weren't that actually that
wrong they were just wrong in her
perspective as a middle schooler but
like I don't know I thought it was like
I'm just like way too good of a dad the
only problem with that is that the wife
in the story leaves the dad we all love
indie movie aaron eckhart but another
part I want to bring up is the sexual
harassment scene where she's in the
backups a senior in high school
presumably senior in high schools cars
youth greater and he comes back and he
tries to get her to take her shirt off
and she doesn't one I like that that's
where it stopped it would have been
believable if more had happened but it
was all almost like maybe weird to say
more but it was like it was definitely
believable that that's where it stopped
and like he seemed like such a like a
like an insecure like kind of whiny
right dude who was just trying to assert
his dominance over this 8th grader right
so it made sense that that's where it
stopped and I also just really enjoyed
not enjoyed but enjoying the fact that
like it made the story makes sense that
how much it affected her and she went
home and I heard her dad together and
and also what also the lack of ability
of the dad to kind of fade like you see
it in that scene where he opens the door
and she's crying yeah and it's like and
he just doesn't you can see he just
doesn't really know what to do this home
movies reflecting back what we're living
through right now and part of that is a
single father raising a daughter and
this situation happens he is
ill-equipped for what to do exactly
all he can give her his empathy and
caring and love and other than that he
doesn't really know what to do
well and later on when they're having
their big emotional moment together he
says that he didn't have to do anything
and raising her mm-hmm he said that she
was the one who was like kind to others
and was like able to grow and he just
kind of watched it happen she clearly
wasn't able to do that right he might
have possibly brought up maybe
counseling
her or like at some point yeah some kind
of like therapy or maybe prescription
drugs right because she's dealing with
such heavy anxiety all the time all of
the characters are imperfect including
the dad which I guess contradicts what I
was saying earlier I think I just felt
that he was too good of a debt like he's
dude like good good and like the
holistic sense of good yeah but I think
that's the drawback of the dad probably
as a human as a human person is that
because his wife left him in some
capacity that were unfamiliar with um I
feel you could tell that he was so
afraid of pushing her away they're all
just so real they all feel like people I
know or want to know I want to know that
Dad but he also has imperfections unlike
that girl I know her she's me like I
feel these people so much and I think it
was just so beautifully done thank you
so much for joining me and thank you for
having me
any literally any time go check us out
next week we're going to Chuck we're
watching to all the boys I've loved
before on Netflix because nothing was
coming out this week so we related dig
deep and people are loving it and tune
in next week
[Music]